keisla
is with us in florida hi keisha how are
you
hi there dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
i asked that because my daughter loves
uh listening you say that
i wanted her to hear you say that but um
my question is i have three paid
settlements
sitting on my credit report right now i
was scammed back into 2018
by a debt consolidation program here in
florida
and i am currently unemployed having a
hard time finding work because of my
credit history
i'm not packing credit checks and
um i
oh yeah okay yeah yeah
yeah it's it's really tough what do you
do what do you do in the banking world
personal banker okay good good okay so
what was the the story was you got
scammed you got into a
debt consolidation and they got you to
settle stuff so you have three settled
on your
account is there any other bad credit on
your account other than three settled
no okay well there are two types of
banks
um big ones that suck
and little ones that don't
well i got this i got big ones that [ __ ]
yeah yeah you're not gonna get a job
with a big wells fargo or but you don't
want one anyway there
uh or bank of america you sure don't
want one there uh
because they are not allowed to think
they're they're not they've given up
their right to think they you're that's
required to work there
you have to just follow policies and so
you're not going to get hired there
but could you get hired at a community
bank
where they're allowed to think yes
because you would have the opportunity
to say
now i want to sit down and interview
with you and in the interview the very
first interview i do
i'm not going to first thing out of my
mouth but while we're talking before i
leave i say now when you get ready to
pull my credit
i want to tell you ahead of time that
you're going to find these three
negative things
and here's what happened they're all
related to each other they're all the
same thing
i got scammed on this one thing it
doesn't mean i'm a doofus
it means i made one bad decision and it
has three bad accounts as a result
i'm perfectly competent to handle a
banking
job that is not an indicator of that but
i did want you know you're going to find
that ahead of time
and if you make your decisions 100 based
on
not the interview not the character of
the person not their talents
only on their credit report then really
i don't want to work here anyway
correct just tell them
i agree tell them and what that does
yeah what that does is it shocks their
system so when they pull the credit
report
somebody actually told them the truth
they don't discover it
it you'll get the job okay i'm gonna try
that now
i am trying to get them off of my credit
report on my own since i don't have the
the means to pay a credit repair agency
you don't want a credit repair
credit repair agencies are all scammed
you can do it
the only thing you can have removed from
your credit report is something that is
reported inaccurately
the federal fair debt collection
practices act and the federal fair
credit reporting act
are very clear on what can be removed
from a credit bureau report and it's
only items that are inaccurate
now these events actually occurred but
are they reported inaccurately
more than likely yes and that's what
i've been reading online there's a lot
of conflicting information telling you
so all you do is this let me tell you
let me tell you how to clean it it's not
that hard okay um
you you write a certified letter to the
credit bureau
and do not give a bunch of details keep
it vague
i am according to the this is what the
letter says
according to the federal fair credit
reporting act
i am challenging the accuracy of this
item
do a separate letter for each item okay
according to the federal law uh you have
since i am a consumer you have
30 days to prove the accuracy of this
item
or remove it you will notice that this
letter was delivered to you
certified mail so i know when the 30
days started
okay or it was delivered to you ups or
fedex with a tracking number so i know
when the 30 days started and then you
will
check it 29 days later and see if it's
still on there
it likely will still be on there because
they are inefficient they will not have
time to have checked it
and if they do not check it or they do
not prove it they have to remove the
entire item
not just correct whatever you think is
wrong with it do not get into
a discussion of what is wrong with it
just challenge the accuracy of it
the chances of them being able to get an
answer back from
that company that you settled with
proving the accuracy of it in 30 days is
zero
okay so it'll get taken off now i will
promise you this though they will
re-report it and it will come back
in two years okay you'll see it again
it's not gone forever
but you can get it off and if you got
all three of them off of there
you've solved your problem right
temporarily
right yeah again okay the the the all
the downloads to the credit bureaus are
done
quarterly and they're they're computer
downloads and so everything that's in
this stupid company that you settled
with files
downloads fresh once a quarter so you'll
get it wiped off
but because they didn't prove the
inaccuracy but then a few quarters later
like a year or two from now they'll do
one of those stupid downloads and it'll
pop back on there
okay and you'll have to do it again the
only way to keep it from popping back on
there is go to the original company that
you settled with
and get them to remove it from their
files so that it's not downloaded to the
bureau ever again
and the likelihood of that's zero you're
not going to get that done
okay good to know now if i write this
letter certified mail like you're
i'm suggesting and they for some reason
or another
write back to me and say well we need
the specific of what is inaccurate
and i'm just trying to keep it big you
know
just say the law says you have to prove
its accuracy
okay i mean i'd go back i would mess
with him
if you want to go back and go that you
know the the whole thing of this you can
write them all you can write them a
an 18-page explanation if you want to uh
the thing is i don't think you'll hear
from them as a matter of fact i don't
think they'll take it off like they're
supposed to take it off and you're going
to have to bug them and go hey it's been
30 days you have to take this off by
federal law
okay okay the federal fair credit
reporting act
it is federal law and you are standing
on that
as a consumer very important for you to
push on them
because here's the thing good question
by the way
there 32
of americans that's one-third have
errors on your credit bureau report
that will cause you to keep from getting
credit
it's reported wrong and it's so wrong
that it will keep you from getting
credit
and 50 i think of the number last number
i saw was 57
have errors of some kind but it could be
as much as they've got the wrong
street number on your house or something
and that won't keep you from getting
credit but they're just
the people doing the data entry are the
bottom of the barrel
and the credit reporting is so
torn up and inaccurate it's such a
disaster yet another reason
that it's laughable that mortgage
companies and other people count
exclusively on fico scores which are
created by all this inaccurate
information
it's absolutely asinine but it's it's
the system that we're working in right
now and it's it's really toxic
it's really a toxic system but there are
a few jobs that will
literally not hire you because of credit
banking is one of them
um and for sure she's got a real thing
there especially with
a big bureaucratic bank like a wells
fargo
a fifth third god why would you want to
work there or a
bank of america god why would you want
to work there but these are people that
are gonna not even
they're gonna just use the credit bureau
thing the negative credit score
or the negative reporting to cull and
push away the resumes
and so it's just that whole thing
so so but yeah you got to look at this
stuff and by the way that whole system i
just used there if you've got something
that is inaccurate for any reason
that's how you can challenge it it may
not come back
but my experience is it usually does
come back because it's still in the
original company's database
and so it will still download in those
quarterly downloads it may be a year or
two later before it pops back
but the first time it ever popped back
on something like that i got so mad i
was like
that thing was gone it's back it's like
oh that's how this works okay i just got
to keep i got to keep scrubbing it
until it doesn't grow back that's what
it amounts to and that's what you'll
have to do is a bunch of times hitting
it
so good question good question thank you
for joining us